[Musique]
l'arrivée d'un nouveau né les vacances
en famille
la sortie pour aller cueillir des pommes
les photos d'enfants sont partout sur
les réseaux sociaux
moi je ne partage pas mais je veux la
famille se sent que ça partagent un tour
quand tu t'es plus pubis dirai que j'y
allais vraiment une photo à la fois mais
j'essayais de la montre et de trois
corps de profil la voyais pas trop ça
m'est arrivé deux fois de mettre une
photo à la rentrée cette année puis à sa
fenêtre l'an passé six ans c'est tout je
me serais que mal de l'avancé 1-0 à 71
trop déjà en 2010 un sondage mené dans
10 pays dont le canada révélait que 81 %
des enfants de moins de deux ans avait
au moins une photo d'eux quelque part
sur internet
sauf que le monde ceux qui sont un peu
naïfs ils vont ils vont trop librement
partager des choses des fois mais sur ce
que les gens voient pas le danger
et puis les dangers connaisseurs massy
imminent que ce qui peut devenir selon
des prédictions de la banque britannique
barclays le partage de photos et
d'informations sur des enfants par leurs
propres parents sera responsable des
deux tiers des vols d'identité de jeunes
adultes
d'ici 2030 prenez par exemple une photo
d'anniversaire ça dévoile la date de
fait l'âge de l'enfant donc sa date de
naissance qui est une information
souvent demandés pour confirmer
l'identité ou encore une photo d'un
enfant avec son chien vous trouvé le nom
du premier animal de compagnie de
l'enfant
une des questions sécurité souvent
utilisé pour accéder à un compte
quand vous avez oublié votre mot de
passe même chose pour une photo de
rentrée scolaire où l'école est
géolocalisé ont rendu public le nom de
la rue de l'école primaire de l'enfant
encore là une question de sécurité assez
fréquent
on sait que les parents ne le font pas
dans une mauvaise intention les parents
ont le sont contents veulent partager le
quotidien mais ne réalise pas ta est pas
toute l'information se disent b j cette
publication le plus seul j'ai pas mis
tant de renseignements mais c'est
l'entièreté de ce qui mit en ligne qui
mises ensemble permet d'établir ma foi
un profil assez complet de l'enfant mais
certains se demandent si le problème
n'est pas plutôt ailleurs
aujourd'hui on peut se faire offrir une
carte de crédit dans un passage qu'on va
la vo port ou dans un commerce
et puis vont te demander en date de
naissance ont adressé des choses qui
sont aucun sens si demain banal et puis
que les gens ont prouvé qu'ils ont nés
quand à donner sens et un peu ridicule
et ici on devrait pas trouver d'autres
moyens de prouver notre identité belge
pour une carte d'identité numérique
quelque chose qui prouve vraiment qui on
est et dont on doit l'avoir sur nous et
si on veut demander une nouvelle carte
de crédit ou transférer une hypothèque
pour faire des choses qui sont en haut
d'un certain seuil faut avoir cette
carte l'aude en notre possession il faut
s'en servir pour prouver qu'ils ont nés
mais ça règlerait pas mal une partie du
problème
en attendant est-ce que la solution
c'est d'arrêter de publier toute photo
d'enfant le commissariat à la protection
de la vie privée du canada recommande
plutôt aux parents de respecter les
renseignements personnels de leurs
enfants comme ils respectueux de leurs
amis je dirais c'est plus d'être
consciente
l'exil des risques et peut-être que
c'est pour tous qui est bon à être
publié